cada vez vamos a hablar de salud ahora
con más romeros a la mar bienvenida ya
estamos aquí pues vamos a hablar de que
cada vez hay más estudios que muestran
algunos medicamentos antidepresivos que
podían reducir los casos de colitis y 9
grave que sabemos sobre esto pues mira
el estudio más reciente se publicó hace
solo unos días es basado en eeuu y
básicamente lo que concluye es que
hubieron un hubo un 30% menos de muertes
por kobe 19 entre los pacientes que
estaban tomando medicamentos
regularmente en medicamentos
antidepresivos como la fluoxetina y la
flujo examina esto se suma también a un
estudio en brasil donde se dijo que
estos medicamentos también estaban
reduciendo aproximadamente en un 30% los
casos de kobe 19 en tonces pues para
comentar estas noticias y todos estos
estudios como cada lunes estamos con el
doctor carlos de eduardo pérez médico
infectólogo de la universidad nacional
de colombia muy buenos días doctor
empecemos por aquí que explica esta
relación que hay entre los medicamentos
antidepresivos
y tener menos riesgo de sufrir coidh
grave
maarten de hace unos meses ya se estaba
estudiando desde hace un tiempo es esa
capacidad que tiene estos medicamentos
estos medicamentos impide la inflamación
del cerebro que es un uno de los
problemas de la depresión y que se hace
a través de mediadores químicos que se
llaman citoquinas entonces al usar este
medicamento se bloquea ese proceso
inflamatorio que es mediado por los
citoquinas que coinciden con algo
similar a lo que sucede en las fases
graves del coi 19
eso hizo colegir a los investigadores
que estos medicamentos al inhibir
selectivamente estas células que
producen estas citoquinas podrían
favorecer un desenlace favorable y así
lo quedo demostrando ese estudio
recientemente publicado
doctor le pregunta entonces qué
consecuencias pueden tener estos
hallazgos en la lucha contra la pandemia
pues es una cosa muy importante el
primero es que son medicamentos que
están en todo el mundo segundo son
medicamentos que tienen versiones
genéricas son medicamentos de muy poco
costo es realmente es menos de un dólar
incluso una tableta y lo tercero es que
son medicamentos que al ser accesibles e
impedir la gravedad de la enfermedad
pues son a una parte de una herramienta
terapéutica que podríamos usar los
médicos en todas las regiones para poder
disminuir esa probabilidad digamos que
es una muy buena noticia sobre todo por
la accesibilidad que tiene los
medicamentos en las regiones del mundo
por supuesto recordemos de hecho que un
tratamiento de las nuevas pastillas que
está desarrollando mer pueden ser hasta
700 dólares por persona el costo que
tiene entonces por ese lado y esas
buenas noticias pero yo quería
preguntarle también que está estos
medicamentos antidepresivos como la
fluoxetina es el componente activo del
prosap son medicamentos fuertes que
regulan la serotonina inhibe los
hormonales en el cuerpo entonces qué tan
que tan sano qué tan seguro es usar este
tipo de medicamentos en pacientes que no
tienen diagnosticados ningún problema de
salud mental
digamos que estos medicamentos son
bastante seguros se usan en millones de
personas y aquí lo importante es que es
un tratamiento no de largo plazo sino de
muy corto plazo se están hablando de
tratamientos de solamente 10 días luego
sin pacto realmente a nivel de la salud
y consecuencia a largo plazo pues no es
considerada porque realmente son plantas
muy corta estos medicamentos no son
equivalentes como las de msd y the
fighter los medicamentos son una
alternativa más que evitan la
inflamación recordemos que son
antivirales directos y son
complementarios podríamos verlo y eso
está por desarrollarse en futuros
estudios sobre la evaluación de los
medicamentos pero son periodos muy
cortos y por eso no van a tener mayor
impacto en la salud de las personas
cripto ahora doctor entonces los
problemas en la salud mental se
consideran un factor de riesgo para el
cob y 19 esto interfiere de alguna
manera en estos estudios
no digamos no interfiere definitivamente
la salud mental es un problema no es la
pandemia es un plan o un problema global
desatendido en la pandemia se exacerbó y
consecuencia de la pandemia pues va a
implementarse el uso de estos
medicamentos es un uso generalizado como
les mencionaba en varias partes del
mundo y probablemente sea una
herramienta más para poder disminuir la
probabilidad de ccoo de cra no es bueno
es muy interesante estos hallazgos por
la accesibilidad como les comentaba y la
mínima impacto que tiene y repercusión
en personas sanas por ser terapias
cortas pero las personas que lo toman
pues tampoco no van a tener ningún
efecto deletéreo en su salud durante la
infección por code por ejemplo y puede
hacer una alternativa pues no suspender
estos tratamientos durante el coi 19 eso
es lo que se tiene que hablar en unos
futuros estudios clínicos
esa era mi última pregunta también para
usted no como hacen falta más estudios
porque por ahora lo que vemos es una
especie de relación estadística entre
tomar estos medicamentos y menos riesgo
de kobe grave pero antes de dar el paso
de usarlos realmente de recomendar los
necesitamos tener más información
una cosa es indicio y otra cosa es
evidencia y en esta mente tenemos es un
indicio del beneficio que podría tener
ahora lo que hay que establecer son
todos los estudios comparativos en
poblaciones segmentadas haciendo los
siguientes químicos para mirar que esos
desenlaces que se observaron pues sean
evidentes y ahí hacer recomendaciones y
luego aprobaciones esto es una una
indicación que aparece en la pandemia
una noticia por la accesibilidad sin
embargo con toda la cautela porque esto
obviamente no tiene todavía una
indicación ni una recomendación médica
es simplemente el inicio de los estudios
clínicos para poderse desarrollar en el
futuro pues desde el inicio y hasta el
final seguiremos esta información con
mucha atención y siempre pues también de
la mano de nuestros asesores científicos
doctor muchas gracias por estar con
nosotros doctor y marc gracias ahora
vamos a darle paso a nuestro segundo
invitado el día